[Music]
turkey is burying its dead
one's crushed while they slept
children parents partners
This Woman's daughter is among those
killed
when her body was found she had her baby
in her arms
the pain is too much
I wish I died and my children had lived
she says
[Music]
Echoes around adiaman
the earthquake totaled much of the city
but people say it took two days for help
to arrive
by which time the voices below the
rubble had fallen silent
so the body bags keep arriving
50 here in an hour
and with them the anger mounts
this woman curses the president she says
she hears her nephew begging for help
from the wreckage help that never came
[Music]
for news
when this apartment collapsed Holmes
became tombs
as Rescuers search for The Hundreds
still missing
relatives watch on
the only thing we have is hope the mood
tells me so we wait to the end
six of his family are buried here he has
little else to lose
whole families died in this collapse
Generations wiped out and this is a
pattern which is repeated tens of times
in this city
thousands of times across turkey
[Music]
for now they will mourn their dead
but with each new coffin the same
question
if help had come sooner could this life
have been saved
Siobhan Robbins Sky News adiaman turkey